vamos a tratar de calcular la suma de
esto que tenemos aquí evaluar esta
expresión de esta suma y hay varias
formas de realizarlo una podría ser por
ejemplo utilizando fuerza bruta digamos
tomamos n igual a uno vemos cuánto vale
esto de aquí cuando n es igual a 1 luego
tomamos n igualados y vamos sumando
todos esos y es un procedimiento que
digamos legal o se hace vale es que es
correcto realizarlo de esta forma pero
creo que es una buena oportunidad para
ver propiedades de esta anotación sigma
que hemos estado trabajando en los
últimos vídeos así que lo primero que
quiero que veamos es que esto yo estoy
sumando tres tres cosas muy bien tengo
la suma de tres n cuadrada más 12 n 4 y
esto yo espero que sea fácil de
convencerte que es lo mismo que la suma
desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de 3 n
cuadrada
3 n cuadrada más más la suma la suma
desde en iguala 1 hasta 7 de 2n que lo
tengo del color morado 2 n más más la
suma
la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de la
constante 4 y esto realmente es muy
sencillo de ver porque en realidad la
suma es asociativa y es conmutativa
podemos ir sumando estos términos y
después arreglarlos para agruparlos de
esta forma yo de hecho te recomiendo que
quien los desarrolles desarrolles este
lado derecho desarrolles este lado
izquierdo y agrupe de tal forma que
puedas ver que si bueno que sé que al
agruparlos estas dos cosas son
exactamente iguales y no es muy difícil
de ver simplemente por las propiedades
de la suma ahora bien este este último
término este de aquí es muy fácil de
calcular piensa que cuando n vale 1 lo
que estamos evaluando aquí adentro es 4
cuando n vale 2 lo de adentro vuelve a
ser 4 y así sucesivamente entonces lo
que está pasando es que estamos sumando
4 más 4 y así varios cuatros cuantas
veces pues siete veces verdad así que
todo esto de aquí son 7 veces 4 que son
y 8 muy bien vamos a ver qué pasa con
esto si nosotros tenemos n igual a 1 lo
de aquí esto de aquí vale 2 cuando n
vale 2 esto de aquí vale 2 por 2 que es
4 y así por ejemplo cuando en estrés
esto vale dos por tres que son seis y
así vamos consecutivamente sumando hasta
que en el vale 7 y 2 por 7 son 14 así
que esto por ejemplo lo podemos ver como
la suma de los primeros 7 múltiplos de 2
o bien podemos factorizar un 2 factor
izamos 2 y esto multiplica a 1 + 2 + 3
así sucesivamente hasta 7 entonces lo
que estamos viendo con esto es que esta
suma es lo mismo que el doble de la suma
desde 1 hasta 7 de los de los primeros 7
enteros muy bien así que esto lo podemos
ver como dos veces la suma
la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de n
de n muy bien y esto por supuesto lo que
me está diciendo es que este 2 puede
salir de esta de la notación sigma
verdad lo estamos
esencialmente factor izando déjenme
déjenme agrupar esto después le vamos a
sumar estos 28 que encontramos acá y
bueno lo que podemos hacer es
exactamente lo mismo con esta primera
suma esto será tres veces la suma la
suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de n
cuadrada muy bien y esto estaba agrupado
y lo sumamos con los otros dos términos
que ya tenemos entonces la pregunta aquí
ya es bueno lo que pudimos hacer fue
factorizar estos números y sacarlos de
la notación sigma ahora la pregunta es
cómo cálculo la suma de los primeros
siete enteros o la suma de los primeros
siete enteros elevados al 4
y para esto hay fórmulas para esto hay
fórmulas de hecho te voy a proporcionar
estas fórmulas en este caso sería tres
veces corresponde a este número tres que
multiplica a y ahí te va es 7 al cubo
entre 3
7 al cuadrado al cuadrado entre 2 más 7
en 36 muy bien esta es la primera de
estas fórmulas
con azul y ahora la fórmula que
corresponde a la suma de los primeros en
enteros aquí voy a poner el 2 que
corresponde a este 2 que multiplica a
multiplicar a lo que puedes ver es como
si fuera el primer término más el último
y luego promediamos y luego esto lo
multiplicamos por
y finalmente me sumamos 28 por supuesto
estas fórmulas lo que puedes hacer es
buscarlas en internet o incluso aquí
mismo en la cana que a demi así que
estas estas fórmulas ya te las estoy
proporcionando digamos ok entonces uno
fácil de calcular es este de aquí porque
tenemos dos veces este número pero aquí
está dividiendo entre dos entonces
tenemos 2 por 7 14 entre 2 7 por 1 + 7
que son 8 así que esto de aquí vale 7
por 8 que son 56 vamos a sumarle estos
28 que teníamos de este lado y ahora
vamos a ver qué hacer con esta parte
lo que lo que podríamos hacer con esta
parte es por ejemplo multiplicar por 3 y
entonces tendríamos 3 por 7 al cubo
entre 3 y 7 al cubo más 3 por 7 al
cuadrado entre 2 más 7 entre 6 por 3 que
sería 7 entre 2 muy bien entonces aquí
podríamos multiplicar por 2 y dividir
entre 2 y ahí lo tienes muy bien
entonces tenemos que calcular vamos a
hacerlo 7 al cubo 7 elevado al cubo es
343 por 2 esto nos da a 686
sí sí bueno vamos a dejarlo así 6.600
686 686 entre 2
tenemos 3 por 7 al cuadrado 7 al
cuadrado de 7 por 7
hay 7 x
otra vez 7 por 7 y eso nos da 49 entre 2
perdón por 349 por 349 49
3 nos da 147 este 147 entre 2 más 7
entre 2 entonces lo único que hay que
hacer es sumar 6 86
147 siento otra vez
686 más 147 más 7 y nos da 840 y todos
los estamos dividiendo entre dos así que
dividimos entre dos y nos da 420 esto
será esto de aquí es
esto de aquí es 420 y si sumamos ahora
420 más 56 28 esto nos da 504 el
resultado final es 504 y ahora si nos
merecemos un redoble de tambor porque
además de todo de que hay muchas formas
de resolverlo y siempre es bueno saber
cómo descomponer el problema ahora bien
estas fórmulas de aquí yo te invito a
buscarlas aquí mismo en la cara que a
demi debe haber vídeos de esto y
deberías ver cómo se deducen yo no soy
fan de ver de dar las fórmulas sustituir
y simplemente ya ahí tienes el resultado
mejor te invito a que el bus que es aquí
en la canaca de mí y que veas de dónde
salen estas fórmulas la la serie
aritmética y la suma de los primeros
cuadrados